all right Colleen hello Colleen uh where
you from org where'd you grow up I'm
from Long Beach California but I've been
down in Seattle for a while just
recently came back up here tell me about
your family growing up you had Mom and
Dad um yeah my parents are still married
um I guess I didn't grow up the greatest
um my dad was abusive and my mom kind of
just let him do it um I started to get
in trouble really young I think I went
to jail the first time when I was
like I don't know 15 cuz my parents were
just like my dad was super abusive and
he didn't allow me to like do anything
so you know that kind of thing where
your parents are too you know
too they don't yeah and so I just
started rebelling I guess you could call
it I was sneaking boys in the house and
so they ended up taking my door off the
hinges and just [__] like that so I just
decided to run away I ran away a few
times and got arrested for that and then
I got into some bigger trouble and was
in jail for 2 years and you finished
high school no I only went up to 11th
grade I think or 10th grade yeah and
that was only because I had an ankle
monitor on and I had to go to school
otherwise I probably wouldn't have gone
yeah are you the black sheep of your
family yeah I would say so yeah where do
you think that comes from is it some
something You' inherited or is it
um the way you were treated probably the
way I was treated nobody you had
siblings yeah I have a brother and a
sister I'm the oldest though were you
treated differently yeah I would say so
yeah my my dad never put his hands on my
little brother or sister he you know
yeah they definitely were treated
differently and they kind of my parents
kind of made my little brother and
sister kind of turn them against me a
little bit so I don't even talk to them
anymore
really yeah when did you get started
working in the
game uh when I was 17 I met a girl in
jail and she uh was doing this and I
just kind of started running with her
and the first couple times I tried to to
you know work I got scared and I
couldn't do it but
eventually something just I guess
needing the money or something like that
just changed and I decided to just go
through with it and then after that it
was all it was all good after that I
imagine it's like getting over that
first hurdle of yeah it was doing this
for money and then once you do then it
becomes easier right I think the first
time I was so scared because it was like
some guy that wasn't we were walking the
track or whatever and I don't really do
that I never really wanted to do that
but um you work the internet mostly yeah
um but it was some Mexican guy in a van
and I just got scared I couldn't do it I
think the first time I ever did it it
was was actually to somebody's house and
that went fine and then after that I was
wasn't scared anymore
so yeah how old are you now I'm 30 so
you've been doing this for over 10 years
yeah way too
long long time yep how does it affect
you
emotionally um I think it's hard in me a
lot just the streets in general I guess
you know make you hard but um
um I mean I guess it's also like a self
like your self-esteem gets boosted in
some way too because you have people you
know telling you how pretty you are all
day and stuff like that but then it's
kind of lonely too at the same time you
know so yeah I find that interesting how
this line of work can can you have guys
admiring you and saying nice things
about you and paying money for your time
and and that's certainly is a
self-esteem boost but then there's
something about it that just inherently
I think well yeah because
it's just I guess it's the way the World
Views people that do that so you know
just the whole stigma around it in
general do you feel like prostitution
should be legalized I think so I think
it would make a lot it would make a lot
of sense it would probably make it a lot
safer for you know the girls that are
working if there was you
know certain like legal things that were
put in place yeah would make it a lot
safer a lot easier I mean [__] I don't
mind paying taxes on it you know
it would be a lot easier and I mean it
only make it only makes it Shady because
it's you know we have to do it you know
on the you know we have to be sneaky
about it whatever however you want to
say it if it was legal then you know cuz
you know bad things happen in
the how do I want to say it were there
things you wanted to do with your life
other than this oh yeah definitely I
never I never planned on my life being
like this but this is just uh what do
you want to do um I wanted to be a
lawyer La believe it or not I'm really
good at arguing so everybody always used
to say that I'd be good a good lawyer
cuz I just like to argue I have an
answer for
everything or see I also wanted to be a
marine biologist which doesn't make any
sense cuz I can't swim so that doesn't
really make sense but I just
like I don't know I like uh the Water I
guess I should learn how to
swim what have you learned about men
doing this kind of
works um that they lie and
cheat and uh most of them are really
strange and uh yeah
I it's made me not be able to trust men
I
guess have you been in love
before uh I think
so I'm not sure if you would call it
love
but I guess I thought I was in love
does this kind of work affect your
ability to believe in
love um yeah I guess you could say that
yeah it definitely makes it hard
to mostly because I mean you're not
going to really find somebody that
really they can say they accept what you
do all all they want but that's not
usually the case you know they just
certain men don't just don't have the
ability to separate the two you know
what I mean cuz what I do is just a job
it's not like I'm going to run off into
the sunset with one of these people you
know I could really care less about them
I just want their money but a lot of
guys aren't secure enough with
themselves to be able to like accept
that and handle something like that so
so you've been doing this kind of work
for over a decade I assume you've worked
with some fims um not really um I I
dealt with a few different people but um
mostly just by myself doing it by myself
you do it by yourself now um I'm in a
situation I'm not going to put any right
labels on it or looking for names
yeah but you're staying in hotels now
I've been living in hotels
for I mean since I was 16 or 17 or 17
yeah really yeah I've been staying in
hotels for the past 10 years I
think
yeah it's not fun and it's really
expensive it'd be so much cheaper to get
an apartment but that's hard to do when
you don't have paycheck stubs yeah you
don't have any proof of right yeah so
cuz I could definitely afford an
apartment it's just getting in one is
the problem yeah so many so many people
that watch my videos of girls that work
the streets are
like they they figure they must be lying
because they're saying they're staying
in motels so that means they don't have
any money but the truth is they can't
get credit yeah that's the problem yeah
my credit isn't the greatest either but
no but you've never worked a job right
you don't have any proof I don't exactly
yeah that's just that's the hard part I
mean it probably cost upwards of like
$3,000 a month maybe to stay in hotels
if you're paying $100 a day you know
crazy I can only imagine how much money
I'd have if I you know saved up all the
money that I ever made oh my God I'd be
a freaking
millionaire are drugs a part of your
life yes opiates opiates started with a
doctor's visit because I have a
fibromyalgia and they gave me bikins and
it kind of
just ran from there yeah is that been a
constant yeah I'd done I I was doing
bikins I was first I was you know just
swallowing them taking them like that
and then that turned into smoking and
smoking pills and then heroin and now F
all I guess
so is that why you're doing this kind of
work you think no but I also don't think
that I could do this kind of work
without the drugs I've tried and I mean
it was nice cuz I had more money because
I wasn't spending it on dope
but to deal with you needed to kind of
well to deal with these people cuz
they're a lot of them are really [__]
annoying you know so to deal with these
people I have to like be high because
otherwise I might
like I'd be snapping on everybody most
likely so I I have to yeah do you have
kids no don't have any
kids don't want any
kids you worked Seattle as well as La
now how was it different
um well before I went I went back to
Washington in 2014 and when I was here
the last time I mean I made so much
money it was you know I couldn't stop
making money it was so much but um
Seattle's a little bit slower I mean
there's a lot of money to make out there
but I thought that there I thought that
it was better here but now that I've
came back again it's kind of changed you
know there's so many girls working out
here that been kind of hard on the
internet at least to make very much
money I
mean yeah Washington's a little bit
different it's it's a lot more uh
like if you're walking the track out
here it's a lot more dangerous I think
than it is out there it's a lot more
stuff going on the gangs here make it
yeah definitely make it yeah so it's
yeah
scary does your family know you're doing
this uh I believe so I've never we've
never actually like said it out you know
I've never said that I'm doing this to
them but I'm pretty sure they know my
mom found an ad of mine on the online
one time when I was staying at her house
it was years ago and I woke up and she
had turned my phone off and um I'm
trying to figure out why she turned my
phone off and she was like oh I found
your ad online and went crazy and so I
had to leave and run off again so I'm
pretty sure they know they just don't
ever say anything about it they never
quite asked me out like straight up if
that's what I do but yeah do you believe
in karma
absolutely absolutely how does karma
affect your life well I try not to do
[__] up [__] to people like steal from
people and you know just try to do the
right thing most of the time but for
some reason I think Karma like has it
out for me or something because I don't
do [__] up [__] to people but somehow
[__] up [__] keeps happening to me all
the time not sure why
but I still try to just do the right
thing you know do you had terrible
things happen to you when you doing this
kind of work um luckily I haven't really
had it anything horrible happened to me
I had a gun pulled out on me one time I
mean I've had a couple clients that have
maybe gotten a little bit aggressive but
there was always somebody there to make
sure that I was
okay but no nothing like nothing super
crazy thank God I've been doing this for
10 years and yeah thank God nothing's
bad nothing bad has happened to me I'm
not sure very many people can say that
I've been pretty lucky but I mostly have
work been working the internet so it's
the internet's a lot safer to work to
work on you know what I mean so you get
guys that become your like sugar daddy
and things like that um I wouldn't say
sugar daddy but I I had regulars yeah
regular they basically were taking care
of me pretty
much paying for my rooms and all that
stuff so yeah what been the hardest part
of this lifestyle for
you
um I guess I would just say
I don't know I mean it's not
really I guess just not being able
to how do I say this you get stuck in
the you know what I mean you get stuck
in it and I guess the hardest part would
be
like you know planning a way to get out
you know what I mean because you just
get stuck in the you get addicted to the
fast money right yeah and I've tried to
work other jobs and I worked at
McDonald's for a couple years but I was
still doing this when I when I was
working there and I even went to
treatment and got clean for a little
while and I would go like um after our
groups and I would go I would have a
room at like the Motel 6 by wherever I
was staying at and I would I would go
and post ads and work while I was in
treatment trying to get sober and one of
the uh one of the uh group people like
one of the people that worked there saw
my ad and he hit me up on on my ad I
don't think he actually knew it was me
at first and was asking me for a date
right and I didn't respond cuz I the
only way I knew it was him is cuz I had
his number saved in my phone because
they you have to save all the like
staff's numbers and so I didn't respond
and um but then eventually somebody else
one of the staff members must have seen
my ad online I don't know why they were
looking online for that but um found it
and told me if I didn't stop that they
were going to kick me out of treatment
so I had to stop doing that but it just
seems like no matter what I I just the
fast money is just too it's too easy for
me I can't do a every two week paycheck
I don't know how I would survive on that
it's like what $5 $600 minimum wage if
you're working that yeah no I can't do
that that's crazy what do you think the
most misunderstood thing is about girls
that do this kind of work that we're all
just you know [__] who just you know
like having sex you know which is
totally not the case I've noticed that
that in a lot of well in any
relationship that I've been
in they just seem to think that we just
like having sex with these people and
I'm not sure why anybody would think
that but it's definitely not the case
and it's really annoying when people say
that it makes me mad like yeah I don't I
don't enjoy the I don't enjoy it I just
enjoy the money that comes with it
that's all it is to me they're like
little dollar signs to me that's all
that's only that's that's how I see them
how do you think doing this kind of work
has changed
you
um I think I used to be a lot less I
wouldn't say angry but just more guarded
and I really don't take like any
[__] I used to be I used to be a lot
more patient I guess well I am patient
in certain ways but I just I used to be
a
lot I guess I guess I wouldn't say naive
but it just made it's made me smarter
and it's made me like just
not trust people
and you know
it yeah what's your biggest regret
[__] um not finishing school
and um I don't know
just sometimes I I feel like I should
have just graduated from high school and
been normal like my brother and sister
you know cuz I don't have a license I
you know I can't get an apartment I
can't do any of that stuff so you think
the the black sheep part of your
personality just kind of snap you in the
ass usually usually does that's why
you're in this situation probably
otherwise you may have stayed in school
you may have a different path yeah I
don't know why I didn't I don't know I'm
just not I'm not good with
like Authority you know well I wasn't
when I was when I was was younger I you
know I just couldn't be bothered to
listen you know it was the way they it
was just it was just too toxic my dad
was a [__] psycho he's still a drunk
and gets drunk all the time and would
yell at my mom and I don't know if he
ever put his hands on her but I never
seen it if he did but yeah it was just
too toxic he's he's a drunk and he has
OCD like severe OCD which I got from him
but like you couldn't even open the
fridge at night time or touch anything
in the refrigerator he would like mop
the ceilings and like just like almost
like some tweaker [__] but but he was
just drunk and has OCD and yeah he was
just mean and I
just and he's also a racist which is a
big reason
why I don't talk to him really or why I
left when I was younger cuz
I all my friends were black everybody
that I've dated has been black so so it
just didn't you
know he would just say he would say
[__] up [__] to people that I would
bring over like race make little racist
comments and they would it would just I
would just be livid about it and it's
like embarrassing too also you know so
yeah yeah not cool how does your OCD
show itself oh
boy um I can't leave the house or
wherever I'm at until everything's clean
and like in its place it makes me late
for everything I procrastinate all the
time cuz I'm always cleaning something
that doesn't need to be cleaned but my
brain tells me like I can't if I don't
do it I'm going to think about it like
all day until I can come back and do it
so yeah it definitely makes me late for
everything and that's annoying I mean
being clean is nice you know but if
you're if it's making you late for work
and making you late for this and that
it's yeah not not great I'm supposed to
take medication for it but I haven't
been
lately what would you say is the most
important lesson you've learned in your
life that's a hard
question I don't know if I've learned
the most important lesson I've Le needed
to learn in my life yet I'm not sure
that's a good answer yeah I think I have
a lot more life to live I learned a
bunch of lessons but I don't know if
they're the most important lesson I
think that's maybe yet to come I'm not
sure Colleen thank you so much for
sharing your story thank you wish you
lots of luck out
here